songwriting is tension and release
you set up an expectation and then you
make people wait just a second
[Applause]
and then you fulfill the expectation
your best tool in the world is your ears
if you have ears and ideas you can make
anything happen
as an artist you will never be satisfied
the trick is to take something good and
bludgeon it till it's great
or set it aside and refine refine refine
your primer fine
in this master class i want to share
with you guys some performance tips
some songwriting tips some studio tips
we're going to take my song savior and
walk through every step of the song
writing process
you can hear how it's doing a kind of
rhythm
to add texture the first lyric really
ought to be
compelling enough for people to go wait
what did you dress me up
please
you got that are any clerk and
statements in the same thing
honestly you'd have to ask her i came up
with the moniker st vincent so that i
could
have the flexibility to be any number of
things
i recorded a lot of my first album in my
childhood bedroom sitting at the
computer like this
i'm gonna play the audio it's so
embarrassing
oh god make shame your friend
because there's no way to get good at
something without being
bad at it first just keep going because
everybody feels
weird sometimes everybody feels like
they don't fit in but
if you can speak to that in a way that's
real you can
move the needle in a more empathetic
direction to the world
i'm st vincent and i'm annie clark
and this is my master class
[Music]
you